[Applaudissements]
la photo que vous allez voir l'événement
les coulisses un petit peu de la
production et de tous se tait les gens
qui travaillent dans ces bureaux
bien sûr les coulisses du bureau là où
est préparé l'émission l'adresse cyril
du bureau essaya des séries par contre
je connais pas l'adresse exacte rapport
ici c'est ou pas pourquoi écouter au
bureau en tout cas il se passe plein de
trucs conscient des informations au
bureau comme j'ai un bureau c'est devenu
une salle de ping-pong regarder bas
quelques amis tout à fait via un vampire
c est ne me proposait ce cover 2
[Musique]
dans l'émission et garance ton salut
corinne ça va maintenant c'est qu'il eut
abaissé courir c'est l'assistante de
jambes chez mr hyper sympa je pas
l'énerver l'âge de troisième tu connais
le principe tu fais photocopies c'est
normal les intrus qui est important
c'est que toi une distance qui se crée
c'est normal parce que je suis un peu
une venait de la télé tous à paillettes
et compagnie vous vois c'est mieux par
rapport au respect comment être dans un
rapport sympa mais qui garde ses
distances quoi ça va très vite avec mon
coeur je suis là haut up chou là je suis
déjà à des questions tu as un truc
ben justement tu connais pas les mecs du
petit journal puisque jeudi ferait bien
faire un petit stage là-bas je vais te
laisser y aller je vis chez les pans de
trois minutes ça rien à voir ce que tu
viens de bien c'est plus une truc
sentimentale ou blanc merci bertrand
fesses de connard cette fois ils vont
m'entendre je suis furibard a pris
quatre ans d'ancienneté dans cette boîte
on m'a piqué ma place de parking alors
que moi tous les matins je réfléchis à
le ton des produits plm est ma place de
parking est un mec tu vois juste est-ce
que tu as une voiture non est ce que
t'as permis non plus pourquoi tu fermes
ta gueule mais bon ils sont en beta
bonjour c'est pas la première fois que
je te dire papa ce talent plus beau cul
du paf était tout permis
[Applaudissements]